a lot of guys wearing man buns yes
lately it is very much a thing it's
trendy I've seen like Jake Gyllenhaal I
love Jake jewelry one around great guy
but Jake Gyllenhaal's but has a man bio
and it turns out turns out there's a guy
who claims he has the biggest Penn bun
in the country I'm not made that his
name is Jace Salisbury and I I met him
and I asked him if he'd come on the show
tonight and he agreed and I thought we
got a feature the biggest men but in the
country I guess that's kind of what
we're here to do or part of our mission
statement sort of our trip National
charter please welcome the guy with our
nation's biggest man bun let's get him
in here
[Applause]
nice ladies and gentlemen
Jase has been growing his hair out for
eight years he refused to cut it that
has cost him several jobs he's a
part-time yoga instructor he has a store
on Etsy where he sells animals made of
yarn it takes him two hours to get his
hair in that shape he has to sleep in a
chair he says it's worth it and that is
a glorious man bun thank you very much
my husband
jace could be near I think that's very
cool and
oh my god it looks like we have a new
champion just wanted his name is also
Jayce yeah he runs a hemp fruit co-op in
Santa Monica
he drinks 20 ounces of patchouli a day
he cries after every orgasm he's a
certified dog masseuse who also repairs
adult tricycles he married his entire
drum circle and he lives in Echo Park in
a hand-built human-sized bird nest that
moves independent of the man it's so
crazy he moves his head and the man bun
is so large he stays where it is I'd
rent that thing out he does rent it out
it has its own zip code
zing I apologize that he's just lazy hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography